PROFESSOR: OK.
Let me then say a little
more about that extra term.
Let's rewrite it in a
slightly different way
so that we get the
feeling of what
it has to do with Hamiltonians.
So this is a coupling term.
So we try to understand, what is
that coupling psi k, psi n dot?
How could we write it?
So what is psi k.
Psi n dot?
To figure this out, we
have no option, probably,
except looking at the
Schrodinger equation--
not really the
the time-instantaneous
state conditions--
En of t, psi n of t.
So you look at this
instantaneous state condition
for n and say, OK, I'm
going to differentiate,
and then I'm going
to make the overlap.
What else could you do?
This is the equation
that tells you
how the instantaneous
energy eigenstate is
supposed to change in time.
So it must have the information
of how to compute this,
or how to rewrite it in
terms of other things
that are interesting.
So let's differentiate
with respect to time.
Differentiate-- respect to time.
And we use dots, as well.
So let's write this as H dot
times psi n plus H psi n dot
is equal to En dot, psi
n plus En, psi n dot.
And then we do what--
we want psi k here
from the left.
So we'll have a psi
k, H dot, psi n plus--
Now you're going to
put the psi k here.
The H will act on the left.
So we will have an
Ek psi k, psi n dot.
That's all that is
left from this term.
The psi k came from the
left and was acted by the H
to give you an Ek times this.
On this state, I have the psi
k already hitting the psi n.
Now, we are interested
in this term
when k is different from n.
These are the couplings to
other states in the analysis
of the adiabatic approximation.
So let's take k
different from n.
In which case, this
term will give 0.
Because k is different from
n and the state just hits it.
And here we have, finally,
En times psi k, psi n dot.
So good.
I think we can solve
for this state in terms
of a matrix element of the time
derivative of the Hamiltonian.
So what do we have?
We have that psi k,
psi n dot is equal to 1
over En minus Ek times psi
k, H dot, psi n, which is--
we can use the
notation H dot kn.
The kn matrix element
of H dot is not
equal to the time derivative
of the kn matrix element of H.
You calculate the H dot.
And you put the kn if you wish.
It really is this thing--
the matrix element of H
dot kn over En minus Ek.
The nice thing of
this representation
is that it now
begins to give you
a feeling of why we care
even about slow changes.
We have, in this coupling term--
this is the coupling term
that will take you away
from an instantaneous
energy eigenstate.
This is the term that can ruin
your adiabatic approximation.
And that term,
now, you understand
that it has to do with the rate
of change of the Hamiltonian,
which, after all, is the
thing that drives the physics.
You could say that
term must be small,
because the instantaneous
energy eigenstates must be slow.
And that's true.
But this equation
makes it clear that you
have here a matrix element or
some information about the time
rate of change of
your Hamiltonian.
And if that is slow,
then this term is small.
And presumably, a small term
in a differential equation
has little effect.
So probably, it's a good
idea to just represent
a particular case
of a Hamiltonian
to just complete
this discussion.
So imagine you have
a Hamiltonian that--
it's of this kind, varies a bit.
Maybe it doesn't vary for
time equal less than 0.
It varies for a while,
and then it stops varying.
And let's call the time capital
T-- the time for the variation.
This is the typical
thing that people do
in the adiabatic approximation.
So that is the
language of things--
nothing, variation during a
time T, nothing after all.
So what is the goal,
the result here?
What is the real
statement at the end
of the day is that
the errors that
appear in the
adiabatic approximation
are all proportional
to 1 over t.
So that is a
mathematical statement.
The 1 over this capital T
controls all the errors.
So if the change
happens very slowly,
the errors go to
0, like 1 over t.
And we can see the
beginning of that,
because I could make a
model of this Hamiltonian
that is a little different.
It just may be a line
growing here, for example.
So this is a
Hamiltonian H of t that
begins as H0 plus t
over capital T times V.
That is for t between
0 and capital T,
and then H0 plus V for t
greater than that capital T.
So here is H0.
Here's H0 plus V.
So if you have this
thing here, you
will have that H dot
is equal to V over T--
capital T. And that's intuitive.
The more time you take to
make this finite transition,
the smaller the value
of the derivative.
And therefore, an H
dot matrix element kn
will be 1 over capital
T, the matrix element
kn of the operator V.
This term, this overlap, will
be proportional to 1 over T.
And this error term in
the differential equation
will be proportional
to 1 over capital T.
That takes still some effort
to show that when you integrate
the differential equation, the
error remains 1 over capital T.
It doesn't get increased.
But that is precisely
the statement
of the adiabatic theorem.
The adiabatic
theorem says that--
and I'll quote it,
maybe, this way.
If you have the norm
of a wave function,
you can define the square root
of the overlap of the wave
function.
And the way people
precisely state
the adiabatic theorem is that.
The state psi, during a time
t minus the psi adiabatic--
the [? n sets ?] for the
adiabatic state of time t.
The true-- the different--
I'm sorry.
The difference
between the true state
psi of t and the
adiabatic approximation t,
for t between 0
and T, is less than
or equal than a
number of times T.
So the adiabatic approximation
that we've written,
the state with all
these phases, is
as close to the real
Schrodinger equation solution--
the error is less
than 1 over T, where
T is this time in which you have
nothing here, nothing there.
And this, in fact, gets even
better for larger times.
So after larger times, the
error doesn't increase.
So you can keep--
the change has already
happened, and it doesn't matter.
So basically, we've
argued intuitively
what the adiabatic
approximation should
be by tracking an
instantaneous eigenstate.
We've now done it with explicit
differential equations.
If you have an explicit
problem, you can, after all,
solve this and see
what things happen,
and therefore, reach the
conclusion that then there are
a good number of conditions.
Many situations,
they're slowly varying.
The adiabatic [? n sets ?]
will give a good solution
to the Schrodinger equation.
So that completes our
first part of the analysis.
Now we're going to turn into
a little different story.